all right now to this important story
medical companies are responding this
morning to a critical new documentary on
the healthcare industry the film is
called the bleeding edge and it speaks
with patients suffering apparent
complications from medical devices such
as the Kobalt hip replacements and the
esure permanent birth control device the
movie claims loose regulations are
putting patients at risk most people
probably believe when they get a medical
device they implanted that those medical
devices have undergone appropriate
testing but for most moderate and
high-risk devices that is not the case
all the manufacturer needs to
demonstrate is that their device is
substantially equivalent as the
regulatory term to another device that's
already on the market Yeshua's
manufacturer Baer recently announced it
would stop selling the birth control
product in the u.s. at the end of the
year due to declining sales in a
statement to CBS News Baer reminded
women with assure that the safety
profile of the device remains positive
and unchanged
it says the phone presents an inaccurate
and misleading picture of assur Baer
argues that the film may encourage women
to pursue risky and unnecessary surgery
to remove the device the FDA responded
to the assur claims stating evaluating
the post market safety of assure
continues to be a top priority well
Kirby dick and Amy ziering probably have
something to say about this they're the
filmmakers behind the documentary called
the bleeding edge good morning to you
both I have to say I think this is
must-see you know I knew very little
about it sure of most of the devices
that you talked about because this is a
huge industry but you're you were here
to really sound the warning bell and
alarms what are you here to say Amy well
it's not just the devices we actually
show in our film it's actually devices
across the board the system is flawed
and it puts the patient's unnecessarily
at risk and that wouldn't mean medical
devices or anything it's it's cat-scans
it's x-rays it's ultrasounds it's hip
implants it's defibrillators it's stents
anything that any interaction you have
with technology when you are in the
medical industry is a medical device and
those are the things that we learned we
were shocked to learn aren't regulated
they are one of the most powerful
lobbying groups in Washington
what are they law
for well they're lobbying to keep the
regulations low right now you know right
I would say right now most medical
devices are the FDA does not require
human clinical testing before they're
implanted in humans and this is just
shocking totally shocking 98% of devices
can be approved for sale without any
studies in humans meaning we are
essentially guinea pigs and we don't
know let's start first without the women
that have been affected by this because
Bayer is now facing 16,000 lawsuits over
issuer what did you hear from the women
about some of the complications that
they suffered it causes an autoimmune
reaction in the body so you can have
migraines absolutely debilitating
symptoms tremors tics seizures all sorts
of things happen and you don't actually
necessarily associate it with the device
it's a gynecological device let me ask
you about what Bayer says which it says
40 published studies involving about
200,000 women demonstrate the safety of
the Essure but we're not discussed in
the film this is what they say so what's
your response to that well first of all
one of the things we learned is that
most studies are actually funded by
industry and as a result they're very
very biased and and one of the big
problems with a lot of these studies is
a shortened planet for life but these
studies often followed women only for a
short time a year a year and a half and
a lot of these symptoms come up five 10
15 years later and the results I have to
say we're devastating it was shocking
what I was hearing from these women and
the the point that struck to me in the
film was when you said new doesn't mean
better new really means unproven I
thought that was a very powerful message
yeah I mean we found that hip implants
in the 70s are actually as effective if
not better than the newer and later ones
but they had to sort of change and tweak
it to charge you more for it so it's
really marketing it's not necessarily
the product I prefer tried-and-true as
opposed to something that they want to
sell me for more money I mean I'd love
something that's tested for a long time
and so that I know is safe before it's
put in my body you see this jock saving
lives oh my god we save lives with every
viewing it has information you simply
can't get anywhere else I was shocked to
learn it Kirby was shocked to learn it
and every screening people say Thank You
doctors thanked us they
know this information I mean I really
that's why we made this you know being
informed consumer by oh yes that's the
best thing you can do mmm-hmm the
bleeding edge means reading it very well
titled - yeah yeah well the technology
that is so cutting edge that is really
dangerous
all right Kirby dick thank you very much
- Kirby I like that name listening my
favorite daughter how's it taste
yeah baby's earring we thank you both